wish you sudak has written in the Sunday
newspapers talking about the deal hasn't
he and he's been very careful to set up
the objectives but also that we uh we're
not there yet
um but we're obviously in a position
where uh we're close to on the cusp of a
deal and I think if we can get that deal
over the line you think you can are you
confident I'm reasonably confident we
won't be talking about it if we didn't
think that there was a good momentum uh
some pragmatism that we haven't seen
before from the EU side but we've got to
get all the pieces in place but it would
Mark A a great deal for Northern Ireland
would protect the Integrity of the
United Kingdom and we would fulfill our
Manifesto I think there's real progress
we want to make sure all the pieces are
in place but I think hopefully there'll
be good news uh in a matter of days not
not weeks